welcome back everybody to our Christmas
special candy cane fences gumdrop
pathways and frosting everywhere those
sound like the perfect ingredients for
the 5s first-ever gingerbread house
competition Greg gets so excited built
the best sweet treat you be the judge
I see a tongue hey hey you I don't
that's why I got you guys what do you
think you are yes we just mean as long
as I have you I can do a gingerbread
house let's do that I loot the beach
[Music]
you have gumdrop Lane and we have look
at this little guy the blue guy is
adorable
[Music]
well here we are dessert for Christmas
day from our family to yours Merry
Christmas Merry I don't think this is
gonna go so well Martha I need help with
this you look like you know what you're
doing here can you give me a little tip
you called the wrong person you're not
good at this all right squeeze some of
that stuff on there this is gonna be the
door one two it's for tall people
I could put Gutfeld on my shoulders and
still get in the front
Oh somebody see it's a nice thing over
here okay okay you know what I think
that's it I think it's done I think
we're finished
I chose a doghouse that's the best kind
of house I'm not sure Jesse Gregg then
the doghouse is not fun
doghouse at my house is always good
though of course I brought my dog
friends with me I've got spikes you
might know from the daily grouping and
then Jasper of course little pro for
coming to Fox News got this fancy little
doodad right here this little dog kind
of looks like Jasper a little bit do you
know I love the Christmas season so I
spent a lot of time building my own
special gingerbread house and then I
threw it away so here it is the one that
I'm doing now look what I did
it's that beautiful I just whipped this
thing together just for you in my own
time oh geez well I guess there's no
take to what I learned if you don't want
to do it again
you ruin the project so they can't do a
second take is that right what really
happened yes you did that intentionally
no no that was by accident
Oh what's your mouth Martha this is a
family show I bet your house did you'd
let people do you let your children eat
the gingerbread house yeah or is it just
for show
well I like I love gingerbread houses
but I'm not good at making them as we
all now know um but yeah we've we've
definitely made them over the years and
then you can break them apart of an item
depends on what kind of it fits like a
real luggage infinity I love gingerbread
- I just like the icing I would just
sacrificing right in my mouth but I like
squeezing that thing what would you call
that device that you just squeeze the
frosting squeezer I love I love that
thing and it's really accurate - that's
like I felt like Picasso got it on your
suit I did where he was sloppy
[Laughter]
hey Marcus like I have a real show by
the way I noticed one big being a
Democrat your gingerbread house had no
fence because my son-in-law is an
architect we had but four supports you
definitely win one who's that he is a
star that kids got great timing he's a
smart guy too
it's better hair than Jessie which is
who's deciding I guess the audience
votes yes and we'll know by the end of
the show right producers we have
somebody tabulating it right now and
we'll have even some of your answers at
some of your comments - right wrenchy
firecracker but Gregor if they if they
pick yours they're gonna have to
reconstruct I know is that great that's
the best thing if that agree it's like
ruins it was over it was over in 30
seconds good job
it's like Christmas to read modern art
yes